we didn't have a lot of Asians man we
had a there was a rumor of an Asian when
I'm not sure it was and I've talked
about this before they had yeah they had
a rumor that there was an Asian kid
right and this is after because we got a
Latino kid
we got a Latino not a family just one
kid well congratulations
one guy one guy Nicholas was his name in
a little bit of light facial hair class
everybody was fired up about that there
was a lot of rumors because yeah people
had never seen that on children you know
it's like wavy light hair other face
yeah like this yeah people are like he's
trying to grow a sideburn on his on his
chin yeah so then I was on the wrestling
team in middle school fetus Kiedis right
there because Penasquitos was 60%
Filipino their wrestling team all the
kids had moustaches oh yeah Filipinos
have moustaches by the time they're 11
I mean is really worth e-mail and mail
is it like a handprint like a
fingerprint
we just grow mustaches like nothing but
we don't really grow the rest though
what we are like Manny Pacquiao
mustaches we all even the female yeah
but I remember like wrestling against
them with the first time and they all
have mustaches and we don't we're like
we're kids you're like bro yeah but our
team was so good yeah that we we beat
them even me I could crush them yeah my
brother who never did Chris is that his
name Bob Steve Steve well there's only
three that's Joe yeah Steve Steve almost
killed a Filipino out there Wow
but my brother had no hair facial hair
and here's this old man with a mustache
that he's fighting against no wrestling
like huh and my brother snapped him on
the ground we're like yeah yeah I'm only
40 I know but it was amazing but anyway
so anyway so the facial the rumor of the
Asian though you heard a
yeah they had a rumour that there was an
Asian boy in Slidell Louisiana which was
probably about 17 miles away and so we
had to get over there you know we fired
up and we thought about it for a couple
of weeks and then we started me on to my
buddy's cut grass man this kid Danny
yeah who was a good friend of mine and
he had some he had a couple different
deficiencies but he's doing okay now
yeah you know and he we raised up some
money saved up some money over two
months and then we called a taxi over
there
yeah and we went to this place where
they're supposed to have you know this
asian boy Chet I want to say the name
was Chet I'm trying to think off the
text somebody change does that sound
the Chet [ __ ] you ever see him sound
it doesn't sound plausible plausible
because I've never met an Asian guy
named Chad yeah there are in Southeast
Asia
there you go either I think it's either
Thai or mate bro check mate so we got
there and he wasn't there it was a
wasn't there the name is from the city
city of Chester England I know and uh
yeah we went there and it was just like
a laundromat somebody had opened up like
a new laundromat or like a cleaning like
a riot clover the others know was it the
Asian run laundromat I don't know that
could have been maybe something else
that got diffused when it by the time I
got to us I know I'm this way
pre-internet yeah this back when what
was the first do you remember the first
time you ever saw an Asian in the flesh
man I feel like it was a man yeah I feel
like it was a man with glasses on yeah
but you did I could probably draw a
picture of them but I don't think that I
could but I don't think that I couldn't
tell you when how old are you
after that I mean I guess I kind of gave
up on it after the yeah after the
no-show of Chet yeah but you would think
that and you know go to you're saving up
money taking a cab because you chat you
don't see them that you would this yours
Nadine to what when you're gonna see
another right so then when you see
another asian i airport or whatever it
you would go oh my god and that would be
in your thing but that's fine yeah
[Music]